in this video lecture are going to
introduce the idea of directed graphs or
digraphs for short so normally in before
this class you might have thought of
graphs and being something like this Y
is a function of X and graphs on the XY
plane but that's not what we want to be
thinking about instead we want to think
about something like this this is a
graph to a computer scientists show a
bunch of vertices which are those points
that you see and edges which connect
vertices being more specific and direct
about this it suppose of a set V of
vertices and they set E of edges which
are composed of two V each the way you
write that out an edge is V comma W that
specifies an edge going from V to W and
in the graph it would look something
like this
note that they are directed that an edge
from V to W is not the same thing as an
edge from W to V in a directed graph
example here we have one directed graph
and you write out vertices as the set of
all the vertices you see there and edges
are pairs of vertices you can also
realize that digraph is the same thing
as a binary relation on the vs. because
each edge just defines a relation from
one version to another so every binary
relation can be drawn out as a graph did
you just put each of the things in this
in each of the sets as vertices and
edges being the things that relate from
one set to the other so now we're going
to find walks and pass now a walk
follow successive edges but it can
repeat vertices or edges for example
when I started at the black vertices see
there you can go to red blue yellow red
and we can go back to blue again there's
nothing stopping us and the length of
these paths is not how many vertices
we've gone through but the
a number of edges that we've got so here
the length would be five because we went
from where the black black to blue blue
to yellow yellow red red blue right it's
not the six vertices that we went
through and you have to be careful about
that that difference of one can kind of
get you a path on the other hand walk
through vertices with that repeating a
single vertex so for example sorry blue
you can go yellow and go red and go pink
and go green but then we're stuck you
can't go back to red we've already been
there so that's it that would be the end
of our path we went to red again then we
have it wouldn't be a passenger not be
if that was path and here the art length
is for it not five vertices and every
graph can be represented as a matrix
representation you draw it out like this
and what we're gonna do is if there's a
edge that goes from one of the things on
the right over to one of the things on
the top we'll put a one at that position
for example there's an edge that goes
from the black to the red so on the
black row in the red column we're gonna
put in a one same thing there's one that
goes from black to green we'll put black
row green column put in another one and
so on for all the edges that we have in
our graph and the rest we just fill in
with zeros and this is called an
adjacency matrix and as you can see
uniquely defined to graph every edge is
represented here and every one of the
vertices is represented here so any
graph can be drawn up this way